so welcome everybody to the last session
of the day
uh welcome everyone to the last session
of the day
um
so uh today we have sean sinclair uh uh
who's a fifth year student at cornell
representing his advisor christina liu
so shawn is gonna basically talk about
um some themes that synthesized some of
the themes from yesterday about regret
and some of the themes from today about
reinforcement learning so sean take it
away
thank you so much steve for the
introduction so yeah like you said my
name is sean sinclair i'm a grad student
at cornell in the operations research
department advised by christina who
unfortunately could not make it today
and also said banerjee as well and so
today i'll be talking about online
reinforcement learning and the regret
formulation and what i think is nice
about this is today we talked about
reinforcement learning yesterday we saw
bandits and the regret formulation and
so today this presentation will be kind
of synthesizing uh these two discussions
that we've had thus far um the
presentation will be mostly at a high
level i'll discuss some ideas of the
proof some intuition and how the
algorithms are developed but i'm here
all semester so if you have questions
about the specifics for some of these
proofs i'm happy to talk about them then
so to start us off kind of the main
question that we've been discussing
today is given a markov decision process
how can we find the optimal policy and i
put given here in quotations because we
saw kind of two different settings of
what this quote-unquote given means to
the algorithm
one setting that we saw this morning
during weiner's presentation i call the
fully known model and this encapsulates
the setting where the primitives of the
mdp the rewards and the transitions are
known and advanced
and the question that people try and
answer
yes this morning we saw algorithms like
value iteration and policy iteration but
the question is how can you understand
the computational complexity of solving
these problems when the state and the
action space start to grow
and so a very good example of this is a
stochastic qe network where every piece
of information about the system the
arrival rates the service rates if you
know these upfront you know the rewards
and you know the transitions of the mdp
so you're in this kind of fully known
model
but the issue with a queuing system is
that the state space is unbounded and so
obviously using these tabular algorithms
that work for a finite state space a
priori do not apply to this setting and
so researchers have studied extensions
to some of the techniques that we
discussed earlier today with value
iteration and policy iteration
adding some levels of function
approximation as well on top of this in
order to learn control policies in this
fully known setting
okay so that was kind of the first hour
of today's discussion was in this fully
known model
the next model that researchers
typically consider i like to think of it
as a generative model assumption and
this is related to street con's
presentations that we just saw and i'll
make that connections clear in a second
and so in this model the the primitives
of the mdp the transitions and the
reward function they're not known in
advance
but what the algorithm is able to do is
sample an arbitrary state and action
pair to observe the next reward and the
transition uh a sample of the transition
distribution for the next state and i
know that shri khan kind of formulated
this by saying you have
a trace from some given policy that's uh
handed to you but there is this extra
condition on that dmin factor
which in order to properly address it
you somehow need to be able to explore
arbitrarily across the system in order
for that term to be bounded in these
settings
and similar to the previous two
presentations we saw
the main question that people try and
address is to understand the sample
complexity for finding a good policy so
we discuss these finite time bounds of
understanding how many samples how long
this trajectory needs to be in order to
learn a good control policy in this
setting
and an example that kind of fits into
this particular model is potentially
like a physics simulator where maybe you
don't know all of the interactions of
the system but you have a simulator
that's good enough that you're able to
use to execute this step here
where you can feed in the simulator a
state and an action and observe a
transition and the reward
for the next step
okay
and
earlier today we saw algorithms designed
for this setting like q learning and td
learning and some extensions with
function approximation that were applied
specifically under this generative model
problem setup
now i think kind of the main motivation
today is trying to answer do we actually
need another setting to reason about
learning control policies in a markov
decision process
and so a lot of problems have restricted
interaction with the environment
that is not captured in these two
different problems like with the fully
known model potentially a priori we
don't actually know what the rewards and
the transitions are of the process which
means algorithms designed under this
setting you can't use them
the second is with this generative model
where potentially you're not able to
sample kind of arbitrarily
along the system in order to evaluate
the next step uh transition
but instead you have kind of a
restricted interaction structure
and so
an example that really highlights
this particular kind of deficit that we
saw with the last two models is with a
drug dosage example and so here we have
a very cartoon model of a little
person along with some schedule that
we're trying to decide of a sequence of
drug dosages that we're going to give
them over the next three days
and so the way that the system works is
you observe some health outcomes about
this patient and for the first day you
decide to prescribe them five milligrams
of some
random medication
you prescribe them this medication you
observe some information some new health
outcomes and you decide on the decision
for the next day let's say it's
potentially 15 milligrams
again you observe some health outcomes
and decide a final dosage for the
medication which we decide to decrease
back to five
okay
and so in this specific problem what we
had to do first was decide on the policy
that we're going to execute
for this particular patient so we
decided on these decisions
we executed it and we observed some data
about this particular policy that we can
then use to update our policy
and
taking this particular example and
putting it back into the previous two
problem setups in order for this drug
dosage model to fit in this fully known
model setting
it would mean that you needed to know
the entire interaction structure of the
problem up front you would need to be
able to say i know for every given
patient for every health outcome and
every drug dosage decision what is going
to happen at the next day which
obviously doesn't make sense so
fully known model does not particularly
apply
and the second model with the generative
model what that is saying is that we can
simulate what would have happened for
any dosage decision
so we could say we could take an
arbitrary patient let's say we want a
sample from some particular like health
outcomes that would mean that we had
access to a patient with that health
outcome we could prescribe them that
medication and observe what happened
next which also doesn't particularly fit
into this problem setup
and so the issues with these two models
motivated what i like to call the kind
of quote-unquote online model
and this is different for a couple
different reasons
so the first reason is that you can only
sample trajectories under a chosen
policy so first you have to pick a
policy you're stuck with that policy you
observe a trajectory under that policy
and based off of that data that you
observe you're able to change the policy
for the next round
so these policy decisions are kind of
made up front
and the theoretical question that people
try and address is try and analyze the
regret that's incurred over time when
you're comparing the policy that you're
playing against the optimal policy in
hindsight
and to some extent you can think of this
as being the kind of quote unquote most
complex
for two reasons
one is that exploration is constrained
so similar to street can't discussion
earlier potentially there's a state
action pair that the behavior policy
doesn't reach and so what would you do
then
that needs to be addressed in this model
because we're trying to learn the
optimal policy and the other issue is
that typically the estimates that you
get
of all of these different
rewards and trying to estimate the value
functions they quickly become correlated
across time because you're using
different policies potentially in order
to collect more data
and
a good example that i like to think that
kind of fits into this model is a memory
management yeah
i didn't know the optimal policy to know
the optical policy you have to do all
these things that you told me i can't do
yeah so uh later on i'll talk about how
you can get a guarantee in terms of a
bet and turn it into one that looks like
simple complexity so you get kind of
guaranteed convergence um but yeah
that's a good point regret as it's
written down you cannot calculate it but
we like it because it gives you the
sample complexity balance i see so i
shouldn't think of i haven't have
occurred so far this but i did not make
that my next decision that's not what
you're trying to tell us yeah yeah so
once we start seeing how the algorithms
are designed they are somehow
independent of the definition of your
event we're just using the data we've
listed
and so
a good example of this is with a memory
management model where
typically you try and use policies that
are designed in this online model setup
for a couple reasons and one of them is
because there's very complicated demand
dynamics that somehow make using this
online model where your policy is
shifting over time
useful in practice and i think some of
this discussion will also be done
tomorrow during the next day of the boot
camp
so i want to pause here ask if we have
any questions about the three different
model setups
great
okay
so
previously so far unfortunately i guess
i missed the memo we have been
discussing mvps in what's called the
infinite horizon discounted setting
everything that i'm going to be talking
about today is specialized to what's
called the finite horizon setting
which is a little bit different so i
want to briefly kind of outline what the
differences are and how we can relate it
to some of the discussion that we've
seen so far
so
similarly to what we've seen
an mdp is defined in terms of these
primitives so we have the state the
action space same thing that we had from
before
the difference is that we have a reward
and a transition distribution but now
they're indexed by a step
and that's so that we can allow the
reward function and the transition
distribution to change over the course
of an episode and so for example
potentially the in the drug dosage model
the reward that we get on day one looks
different from the reward that we get on
day two so we add this additional
dependence on the current step
and this last variable h is called the
time horizon and that's the number of
decisions that you're trying to make
and so previously in the example
with the drug dosage model we decided
three decisions for the drug dosages for
the three different days and so the
horizon
capital h is going to be equal to three
for this particular problem
okay
and the last bit
is this bit on the bottom
where now previously we only had to look
at stationary policies so policies that
did not depend on the time step
but intuitively you can think because
the reward and the transitions also
depend on the time step the policies
that you consider should also depend on
the time step here
so our policies have this additional
dependence on the time step that we've
listed at the bottom
okay
so this is the main difference
between this and the models that we
discussed earlier is instead of a
discount factor that's included we have
a finite time horizon after which
the problem is finished we make the
three dosage decisions and the policies
are no longer non-stationary yeah
yeah so the time could be part of the
state space and then you can eliminate
this but then it just so happens that
policies have to be step dependent even
under that setting and so the reward and
the transitions not depending on the
step is not super important um but
because of the finite horizon the policy
has to depend on the current time step
and i guess you could think of a good
example for this is you could consider
some maze where you're given 50 moves
so what you would do first is go to the
goal location and then just go left
right left right left right left right
continue to accumulate that reward from
the goal state
so
the policy that we have to consider has
to be indexed by the time step
and there is a relationship between
this model and some of the models that
we discussed earlier
for example typically you can take this
time horizon here it is fixed and known
but if you let this be a geometric
random variable
with parameter gamma then it turns into
the same problem that we saw before and
because the geometric distribution is
memory lists the policies are now not
step dependent but
somehow not important for the discussion
that we'll be doing today
okay
and so
with this
i wanted to flash the bellman equations
here i've also written them over on the
side here because we'll be referring to
them a lot um
and just to point out the two
differences from what we saw previously
so just like policies are now indexed by
time the q function and the value
function also have to be indexed by the
time step h
okay
and previously
we defined the q function in terms of
reward plus gamma times the expected
value function
but now because all of these are
additionally indexed by the time step we
have the q function for a time step is
the immediate reward plus
no discount factor here
the value function at the next time step
okay
so everything here now is also
indexed by time steps and so you're
relating these q functions at one time
step to
these q and these v functions for the
next time step
but
again all of this could be related to
the infinite horizon discounted settings
similarly to
okay
do we have any questions about bellman
equations mdp problems stuff like that
great
so
i kind of sketched before
what this online model was
i said
one aspect is you're only able to sample
trajectories under the currently chosen
policy and use that in order to update
the policy for the next round
and again the question that people try
and tackle is to look at the regret
which is incurred over time when you're
comparing the value of the policy you
play versus the value of the optimal
policy
and again i want to emphasize that the
transitions and the reward distribution
is not known to the decision maker
and so the way that the interaction
structure works
is
over what's called a sequence of
episodes
first what you have to do is pick a
policy
and the drug dosage model that was the
policy that we are picking for this
particular patient so we picked it up
front that is the policy that we're
going to play for this particular
episode
we then take that policy and execute it
in the system
over the h steps
that governs the finite time horizon of
the mvp
once we've executed it
we are able to collect some data set
similar to the presentation from srikant
the data set that we observe is a
sequence of state action and reward
pairs but now there is a finite time
horizon and so we
observe h of those pairs where h is the
time horizon of the model
and with this interaction structure
just want to kind of reiterate
now we have these two parameters that we
really care about one of the parameters
is h which is the number of decisions
that we're making over time and the drug
dosage model we had three days so our h
was three for the three days of
decisions that we have to make
and we have this additional parameter k
which for this drug model you can think
of it as the number of patients that
we're kind of running this experiment on
going one by one changing our policy
over time
and so h and k are kind of related
to
each other and also similar to the
discussion that we had yesterday where k
you can think of as t
and the multi-armed bandit problem set
up it's the number of decisions that
we're making where each decision
our h is equal to one because we're only
making a one-step decision and observing
a one-step reward
and lastly our goal the theoretical
quantity that we try and analyze is
regret
so regret is defined in terms of the
total number of episodes where you sum
up over each episode looking at the
value of the optimal policy and
subtracting off the value for the policy
that you played for that particular
episode
okay
and
similarly to what we had discussed with
the multi-armed bandits problem set up
yesterday
initially the regret would scale
linearly with respect to k that's if you
were not learning anything at all and so
the goal is to show a sublinear regret
guarantee for the algorithms that you're
proposing
and just to kind of take this and relate
it back to the question from before
you can show that if you have some type
of sublinear regret guarantee all of
this is wrong up to constants that i
just didn't put in but if you have a
regret guarantee scaling in terms of
some way let's say it scales in terms of
square root of k you can take that
guarantee and swap it into a sample
complexity guarantee
where you also get in terms of the
number of samples required to learn an
epsilon optimal policy which scales in
terms of the regret guarantee that you
had here so if alpha is a half then the
number of samples is one over epsilon
squared
so
we have
yeah
do you have constraints on the kind of
policies you can choose
yeah um so
you can choose for the time being you
can just pretend that we're considering
in the the finite state actions based
settings so you can consider any
arbitrary policy from the state space to
the action space
so you don't have because you're
motivated by like some policies are kind
of crazy in the medical setting but you
don't have that here
yeah um so later on actually we'll
discuss about potentially restricting
the space of policies that you consider
um but for the time being you can kind
of consider arbitrary ones yeah
be awesome the strongman solution would
it be reasonable to just discretize the
space of all policies and then just use
one of the algorithms
yeah so that's a good question
so one solution you could do is consider
every single policy we know in this
setting and in general that
deterministic policies are optimal and
so there is a finite number of
deterministic policies but the issue is
that the number of policies you would
need to enumerate over scales
exponentially with the number of steps
because you have to make a sequence of h
decisions so the policy
space scales exponentially with respect
to h and the regret guarantees that we
will get will be better than exponential
yeah
but that is i guess something then it
would still be some linear in k so at
least you get some you know
some sample bounds
get you started
yeah yeah that is a very good point that
when you're looking at this regret style
analysis you'll see that people will
kind of assume certain things are
constant and let other things scale and
that is important because if you were to
enumerate every policy the regret would
be you know constant if k was large
enough
right but then that constant is
exponential in terms of other primitives
like the horizon
yeah good point
is setting does it make sense to say
either polynomial or logarithmically
yeah you can think of h as being some
nice polynomial of that but um later on
when we discuss regret bounds i'll
briefly mention that people look at
ways that you could pay exponentially in
terms of some components in order to get
you know better dependence in terms of
other components
but should i think of h as given or
something that i can tune because it
isn't an episode something that's like
naturally occurring yeah yes so you can
think of the
the horizon h is something that's known
and finite and obvious
okay
so something that we discussed a little
bit briefly in the presentation so far
but i want to kind of emphasize in a
little bit of a different way because it
forms the fundamental for a lot of
different rl algorithms that we've
discussed so far
and so this kind of fact that we need to
do is to be able to compare two policies
okay
and we'll see later on how this becomes
important for picking different
particular policies that you're
comparing but for the time being let's
say you have some reference policy
that's the one that you're currently
using
okay
and then you have some other policy
which will denote pi alg and that's the
policy that you're trying to kind of
optimize over or pick for the next
episode
okay and you want a way to be able to
compare their performance
and so suppose you're at some state
and you notice that the two policies are
proposing a different action the
reference policy is proposing to go down
the algorithms policy wants to go up
okay
and what you're trying to understand
is okay we know the two policies they
differ on this action and so how much do
you have to compensate
quote unquote in order to compare the
performance at this particular step
of these two different policies
okay
now for just looking at one step
what you could do is look at the
immediate rewards
so the reward that the pai aug is going
to get is the reward for being in the
state where the action is dictated by
the algorithm's policy
that's how much you get immediately from
going up
okay
and then if you go down you follow the
reference policy the reward you get is
the reward for being in the state
following the action by the reference
policy
and so an actual thing
to kind of write down as a compensation
is just this difference
okay the difference of the reward that
we get for going down versus the reward
that we get for going up
okay i haven't really done anything yet
i just wrote down rewards right and i
subtracted them
okay
but for this we can look back onto our
bellman equations here i wrote down the
optimality ones but the
ones for a particular policy look
similar where the max is replaced with
the action taken by the policy and with
this equation we can subtract off the
value function
for one of the policies in order to
transform it
that exact same difference to be equal
to this term right here
and for some intuition behind it
what this right hand side term is doing
is it's just looking at the value for
playing the decisions made by this new
algorithm that or this new policy that
you're proposing pi alg
and on the left hand side we have the q
function
which from before we saw was what is the
immediate reward we get for taking the
reference policy
so that's the one step reward that we
saw
from before
but then we switch into this new policy
pi alk
okay
and this term is important enough
that people in the rl community have
defined it something new
called the advantage function
which is just defined to be this exact
difference right here the difference of
the q function and the v function
where here pi out you're writing the
policy you're taking for all of the
subsequent steps
and here for pi ref
you're indicating the action that you're
taking right now
and they call this particular thing the
advantage function
now the signs on this quantity are crazy
okay it's really hard to think about and
so for example
ignore what pi ref is we don't really
care what we're doing now what we want
to do is find the optimal policy
let's suppose somehow we're able to
guess
what the optimal policy is and so pi out
is actually the optimal policy
okay
then
here we're looking at q star of s for
some action
and subtracting off with v star of the
state
and so the advantage function for the
optimal policy will be negative
meaning that if we switch to pi alk
we're able to improve our rewards which
is somehow counterintuitive because of
the negative but we'll see kind of where
it comes out in a second
okay
so i'll stop here ask if we have any
questions but i just want this kind of
comparison to stay in the back of your
brain because we'll be using it a couple
times when we talk about designing
algorithms
yeah
if i follow the optimal policy for one
step and then follow it for the rest of
it
so the difference is if you plug in pi
star here
you're telling the optimal policy oh you
want to play some action
don't do it play some other action
oh i see so pirate is not okay good
and so if pi and pi ref are both the
optimal then it's zero right but pi ref
is what we're currently using and we're
just kind of supposing for now that it
is not optimal
great
so
we're now ready to start the discussion
about algorithms
earlier in this kind of fully known
model setting we discussed two different
approaches for designing algorithms
one of them was called value iteration
and the other was called policy
iteration
and we remember when we actually
executed these steps these one-step
update procedures
we very heavily relied on this fact
because we were evaluating the q
function for a given policy which you
can only do if you know the transitions
and rewards and when we were doing
policy improvement we were plugging in
this transition distribution
so apriori these two algorithms
to some extent they don't initially work
but similar to srikant's discussion
for the online model we've developed
algorithms that fall under both of these
buckets
that are called value-based and
policy-based approaches
and
for the first part of the presentation
i'll be
briefly discussing some of these
policy-based approaches just to
highlight some things that are missed so
far and then the rest of the
presentation will be focused on the
value-based approaches where we'll
discuss the algorithms more concretely
discuss the regret guarantees they're
able to achieve and so on
and so we're going to start off with
these policy-based algorithms
now something that was kind of alluded
to earlier was you have to like if
you're running a policy-based algorithm
you have to actually like pick the
policies that you're going to be
optimizing over so srikant kind of
proposed this particular form of
policies that are defined in terms of
this known feature representation and
earlier we had this question of like are
you considering every policy or you're
considering some restricted class
an example that i like
that i think particularly highlights
this is with inventory control
particularly the news vendor model
the way that this model works is you are
some kind of newspaper salesman let's
say and you have some current inventory
of newspapers that you have on hand
each day some demand comes that are
buying some of the newspapers and you
have to decide how much you want to
order for the next time period
and people in the operations research
community have studied this problem
extensively and
come up with a particular
parameterization for these policies
called base stock policies
and the way that base stock policies
work is if your inventory level is below
what's called the base stock level
you order up so that your inventory for
the next time step is equal to that
level
but if your inventory is above the level
you don't order anything
and you can kind of write as a picture
this particular choice of policy like
this where you have the inventory level
on one axis
the policy on the other where if your
inventory is zero you order up to the
base stock level
if your inventory is equal to the base
stock level you don't order anything and
above it you also do not order anything
and this policy here is parametrized by
one variable s
that we can think of as parameterizing
the policies that we're going to
consider in the mdp
and so typically when you kind of take
this rl formulation and write it in
terms of optimization you can think of
this particular parameter s as this
theta this parameter for the problem for
the policy that you're optimizing over
and so these policy-based algorithms try
and solve
this particular problem instead where
you're trying to maximize the value
of the parametrized policy in some space
of possible policies where theta could
be s
characterizing the base stock policy
that you're optimizing over or any other
parameterization
do you have a question
okay great
um and so
this a priori it's kind of
weird to see the dependence on theta
it's somewhat non-obvious and so what
people typically do
is they just rewrite the value function
and just write it as some function j
that's only a function of theta
okay
and here when we write the problem in
this way
we have an optimization problem okay
there's some objective function
okay we can't really evaluate it we'll
address that in a second but there is an
objective function that we can write
down find in terms of a parameter that
we can also write down
and write it in this way
and with this
it's somewhat clear that you can use
existing optimization algorithms applied
to this like gradient descent
and
i put an emphasis the fact that it needs
to be stochastic which we'll see why the
algorithms you should use need to be
stochastic and that's because you can
evaluate j of theta but we'll talk about
ways that you're able to kind of
estimate it from data
and so this has been done across a
variety of different optimization style
algorithms with zeroth order or gradient
free optimization algorithms gradient
based are also hessian-based
optimization algorithms
okay
but
remember from before i said we have this
objective function that we cannot
evaluate because we do not know the
model
okay
and so intuitively you can think of all
of these algorithms
they really don't depend on what the
objective function is
they depend on your ability to do
comparisons
and so a primitive to all of these
optimization style approaches
is
how can you compare the value of two
policies
and
you can think of this as just doing kind
of grid search
for the threshold level for the base
stock policies potentially we cannot
evaluate this but if we're able to
evaluate the difference in the
performance of two base stock policies
we're okay because we can do kind of
standard
kind of grid search procedures and this
is also readily witnessed if you're
doing zeroth order optimization where
you take your current parameter
evaluate policies in a grid you only
care about the differences because we
only care about one step improvement and
by being able to do a comparison you're
okay to take one step of the algorithm
and so as a primitive
essentially all we need to be able to do
is compare value of two policies
and so
looping back to our discussion from
before
previously we looked at
comparing two policies your current
policy pi ref
some new policy you're optimizing over
payout looking at just one steps
difference of rewards
but our objective is a value function
so in order to look at the difference of
the value functions
you can just take this quantity you can
take this one step difference
and sum it up over the trajectories
and so this principle here of looking at
a one-step compensation and summing it
up over the trajectories
gets to probably what is one of the most
famous results in reinforcement learning
called the policy difference lemma
and what the policy difference lemma
looks like
is
looking at the performance of two
policies
so the value for one policy subtracted
with the value from some other policy
in order to evaluate the difference of
these two policies you take an
expectation over trajectories from one
of the policies your current policy your
reference policy
of
this advantage function on the hand side
of the proposed policy
this new policy pi out
okay
and so
this kind of relationship
of this one step compensation taking an
expectation over the trajectories allows
you to recover this policy difference
level
okay
now
this is useful for a multitude of
reasons
one reason that's useful is okay if you
had perfect information
you can evaluate this quantity exactly
in order to guarantee one-step
improvement
so with perfect information you can do
grid search
to be able to compare performance of
policies to be able to take one step and
improve your policy at the next
iteration
okay but we don't have perfect
information
we can't evaluate these quantities
exactly
and so what's nice about this and i
won't go into the details is you're able
to evaluate this using monte carlo
rollouts under your current policy
where the way that you're able to
evaluate at a high level is
taking trajectory sampled according to
this reference policy
doing importance waiting in some way in
order to evaluate the advantage function
and combining those two facts together
to get an estimate for this
here the quantity on the
destitute of the different states
yeah yeah so when you're actually doing
the monte carlo estimates and evaluating
the performance of these policy-based
algorithms you have terms that look like
this
and so typically when i said you could
use any optimization algorithms
somehow not true
and so in practice what people do is
they
take optimization algorithms and modify
them in a little
so that you're only taking small steps
so that the variance that you'll get
that's hidden here isn't super bad
and that's to some extent one of the
biggest downsides of policy-based
algorithms is you're introducing
additional variance by doing this
important sampling but in practice it
works super well
okay
so
this difference that we took you could
use it as kind of a
primitive in order to do zeroth order
optimization i'm not going to go into
the details but
the other optimization approach you
could do is a gradient based
optimization algorithm and so we need to
be able to take a gradient
of this objective
which by taking that analysis that we
had before to be able to compare two
policies
somehow a finite difference take the
limit in order to get the gradient
and you get what's called the policy
gradient theorem
which is maybe one of the second most
celebrated results for rl
i guess the order
potentially is debated what's the first
what's the second
but the way the policy breaking them
works is you have an expectation under
some policy
this advantage function we saw before
again but taking the derivative of the
current policies the log probabilities
under the current policy
again what's nice about this you can
evaluate it under monte carlo estimates
of the current policy that you're trying
to evaluate the gradient under
and so these two terms the policy
gradient and the policy difference lemma
with some modifications to the
optimization algorithms allows you to
use existing techniques from
optimization and apply it to rl
where we have the primitives to be able
to do the comparisons because we can't
evaluate this objective exactly
and use our standard optimization
algorithms from there
so are these houses or knowledge
oh are you just trying to find the test
yeah so the regret guarantees for this
style of algorithms is more recent
i mostly wanted to put it in here the
for the most part the regret guarantees
look at the generative model setting but
i wanted to put it in here because it
had not been discussed yet so far and i
think that really understanding regret
guarantees that this style approach is
something that could be looked at in the
future
yeah good question
okay
yeah
do we know
something the conduction speed boxes
yeah so people have studied the
convergence guarantees of monte carlo
rollouts of this and plug that into
convergence guarantees of the
optimization style approaches i can't
recall off the top what the exact form
guarantees look like but um some of the
papers that are disappeared
okay
yeah just so that i am
not completely using you so basically
you're trying to figure out the optimal
theta for this thing yes
using this
steps yeah this is basically like a
stochastic gradient
yeah
so that to some extent really helps us
what we're going to think about next is
okay we're like we're using and in
practice people use gradient based or
zeroth order optimization algorithms and
they ignore
what the what the subjective function
looks like this j of theta
like potentially it's not times x
potentially it's not smooth but you just
apply and hope for the best and in
practice these algorithms really work
well
okay but there's also been growing
theory behind these two that i want to
talk briefly about just to kind of
highlight some two papers in the space
so the first one
to some extent
mentioned briefly by shipra yesterday is
to first consider a restricted class of
policies
so i am in an or department
and one of the things that i really
enjoy that people in or do is they study
fundamental models and come up with
policies
that are provably near optimal in this
specific setting and so going back to
inventory control one of the reasons
that we like bay stock policies is
people in the or community have studied
them extensively and shown that they're
provably near optimal you can increase
the scale of the problem you can add
complexities to the underlying inventory
control model but this simple base stock
policy still works very well
and so once you restrict your class of
policies this j of theta is not some
random j of theta it's now the j of a
particular base stock level
and so in this paper they exploit
additional structural properties about
the value function for particular
parameterized policies
for example potentially this particular
value function is strongly convex which
means we're able to get optimization
guarantees
and we can evaluate potentially it
exactly over traces like the estimation
problem suddenly becomes much simpler
and so this is one way that you can
think about using this on a particular
application is
study the application in theory come up
with a restricted set of policies that
work well
use gradient-based optimization
procedures on that restricted class
the second approach that i also really
enjoy and wanted to mention is a paper
by dan russo which
for those of you who are not
participants uh in the fall of 2020 the
coveteer there was a theory of
reinforcement learning program at
simon's and there was a presentation by
him at one of the boot camps on this
particular paper so if you're interested
i would heavily recommend watching it
and what this approach does is it
characterizes conditions
under which this particular objective as
a function of theta doesn't have any
local maxima
so you know if you're doing a gradient
based optimization procedure you are
okay
because every optima is a global one
and the two assumptions are quite nice
the first one is kind of natural you
need some additional differentiability
and some continuity assumptions on this
j of theta
relatively standard and makes sense what
it's required for
the second one
i think is particularly beautiful
and the requirement is that the policy
space is closed under what's called
these policy iteration steps so if you
take a policy do one-step policy
improvement
the new policy is also in the policy
class
and in the paper they discuss about a
particular application with lqr
somehow makes sense
with the reward function and by
maximizing a linear function you are
able to recover the lqr policy again
makes sense something
somewhat interested in queueing theory
that i've personally looked at is under
specific settings with stochastic qe
networks you can also come up with a
parametrized class of policies that
satisfies this particular assumption so
that you can use gradient-based
optimization guarantees and
provably converge to the optimal policy
yeah so um
so that's not enough uh oh was the
question in this application whether it
contains optimal policy or does this
assumption imply
closure under the optimal house
yeah so you need this plus extra stuff
you need this you need this closure
assumption too so you know the optimal
policy satisfies it because it's a fixed
point right but you need the
parametrized set of policies you're
optimizing over to also be
closed in this way yeah
[Music]
so
with this
we have yeah another so
we have state spaces
[Music]
yeah so that is an additional problem
that i'm ignoring when i said that this
is an example that satisfies this
assumption that you run into when doing
it in practice and so chaomin has a
endeavor watch out have a nice paper
where you somehow like
i i think of it as like regularized by a
stable policy so that you're guaranteed
to stay within the space of stable
policies as well but when applying these
types of algorithms for qa networks
definitely that's something that needs
to be done
um and also
going back a little bit
just like we have this policy difference
lemma in the queueing literature people
have also studied approaches to look
like this to be able to estimate whether
the new policy you're optimizing over is
also going to be stable
um which can talk about offline how it
fits in
okay
great so with that we are somehow
concluding our discussion on the
policy-based approaches and moving on to
the values
and
last minute questions before we kind of
shift gears
so
a lot of these value based
value-based algorithms really are
wrapped around these bellman optimality
equations
which are written as here and also on
the side here for you to be able to look
at as we discuss the algorithms
says that the value for the optimal
policy is a maximum of the q function
for the optimal policy
q function for the optimal policy is
immediate reward plus expectation over
the state transition distribution of the
value for the optimal policy under the
next time step
but again
we cannot evaluate these bellman
equations because
this term here transition distribution
and this term here the rewards are
unknown
and so to address this within the class
of value-based
approaches to learning control policies
for regret minimization there are two
types of styles
called the model based in the model 3
setting
and so the model based the way that it
works is the two unknowns here the
reward and the transitions
let's take your data set
we'll estimate it
take those estimates
plug them in here estimated reward and
an estimated transition and solve these
bellman equations
okay
you're not exactly solving the bellman
equations because you're not plugging in
the actual reward and transitions but
you're approximately solving them you
take those estimates
play the action that's greedy with
respect to those estimates which makes
sense
and
what's important about these policies is
the time complexity and the space
complexity it scales as h s squared a
which arises from maintaining an
estimate of this transition distribution
which has an h dependence an s and an a
dependence and another s dependence for
the output of the transition
distribution so that's the time and the
storage complexity for the model based
algorithms
okay
the model free algorithms so related to
srikant's presentation from earlier like
we didn't really see it was discussed
how this could work but we didn't see
these model-based algorithms
specifically we mostly focused on
model-free algorithms that estimate this
q function directly
by applying this like bellman optimality
operator
you again play greedy with respect to
those estimates and the time and the
storage complexity is better
because you're not storing an estimate
of this exactly
and so it's only hsa for the size of
this
three tensor indexed by steps states and
actions
and so the rest of the presentation will
briefly describe these two algorithms
talk about the regret guarantees and
some open questions that lie within the
space
okay
so
a beautiful paper
which outlines some of the regret
analysis under these style of
value-based algorithms formulates it
like this that i want to briefly kind of
sketch and it's very much related to the
same optimism principle that we saw
yesterday for the bandit literature
and so the way that a lot of these
value-based algorithms work is
let's suppose you're in some arbitrary
state at some arbitrary step
and you have three different actions
these orange lines here
are the
actual optimal q function okay that's
unknown
and so
because
this one is the largest we know that the
optimal policy plays action a1
okay
and the way that the algorithm works is
initially
you estimate
the q function to be its maximum
possible value
which if you say the reward is bounded
by one
the maximum possible value for the q
function is the number of time steps
remaining
for the horizon which is capital h minus
little h where little h is this current
step that you're considering
okay so that's these greenish lines that
we have on the top
and so initially we said our algorithm
was playing greedy with respect to the
estimates
so we're somehow going to randomize
among these three different actions
let's say we pick the second and the
third action
okay
and we get some new data
and we somehow update our estimates
we'll talk later how we actually update
the estimates but for now we just update
them okay
now notice that our estimates are still
above the true value
so we maintain optimism
but a1 is now the one that we're going
to play because we play greedy with
respect to the estimates
so we play a1
update our estimates in some way
oh
we saw
now they're about the same so we play
randomly again
and continue like that
okay
and what happens after a while
is for some of the actions
we're able to rule them out
just like the bandit setting
and converge on the optimal action being
a1
and so
this paper formalizes a way that you can
get design and analyze the regret
guarantees for this style of value-based
approaches
um and also want to emphasize that
similar to the banded setting you'll
notice that the estimates converge to
the true value
previously it was for the optimal action
now it's a little bit more complicated
the estimates converge to the true value
for the optimal actions on sample paths
under the optimal policy so it looks a
little bit different but when you run
these algorithms in practice you'll
start to see pictures like this where if
the optimal policy
if it visits the state
you'll see that the estimates converge
for the optimal action and the other
ones don't
and so
the paper that i have listed at the
bottom
shows kind of three invariants that a
value-based algorithm should satisfy
in order to be able to analyze its
regret guarantee
the first invariant
is that you're maintaining estimates of
the q function
they should be optimistic
which means that with high probability
they're larger than the true
q value that is unknown
similar to the multi-arm bandit settings
where
we maintain estimates for the mean
reward that we're with high probability
upper bounds on the actual mean reward
the second property that we do
these estimates should be
somehow non-increasing and they need to
decrease quote-unquote fast enough
which you can think of saying that they
decrease at a rate of one over square
root of t
where t is the number of times you have
been in this step played in this state
playing this action
okay
and the third property is just that you
have estimates for the q function the
policy that you play should be greedy
with respect to these estimates
and using these three principles
you're able to come up with a regret
guarantee that's very general that
allows you to analyze essentially an
arbitrary value-based algorithm that
satisfies these three different
assumptions
i'll also highlight later that this
paper does some additional stuff too
but for now can just say you get a
regret guarantee for algorithms that
look like this
so going back to the two style of
algorithms the model based on the model
free we'll start off with the model
based algorithm
so the way the algorithm works is you're
at some episode you have a data set
you've observed so far the state action
next state reward tuples
yeah so this results you can take parts
of it and use it to analyze an arbitrary
value-based policy that satisfies these
three different assumptions they propose
a policy and analyze that one you can
take their same analysis
um it's somehow general enough take
their same analysis to analyze arbitrary
algorithms and so in a second i'll talk
about how people have used this style of
framework to analyze model 3d model
based other styles too
so for the value-based algorithms
start an episode you have a data set
take your data set
estimate the reward and the transition
distribution with an empirical estimate
we're in the tabular the discrete
setting so empirical is okay for now
okay
estimate the reward and transitions
then you just take those estimates
you have the bellman optimality
equations here
plug them in for the unknown reward and
the unknown transitions
and so the way that the estimates are
obtained are by solving this dynamic
program where you put in an estimated
reward and transition function into it
so just like the bellman optimality
equations
the estimate for the value function is
the maximum of the estimate of the q
function
the estimate of the q function is the
reward
but we plugged in the estimate
an expectation
but we plugged in an estimate
of the value function
but again we plugged in an estimate
okay so it's essentially take all of the
terms for the bellman optimality
equations and put a bar on top of it
and the policy that you play is again
greedy with respect to the estimates of
the q function to follow into that
optimistic style of algorithm from
before
and you'll notice i have one additional
term here
which is the exploration term just like
we saw with the ucb style of algorithms
that scales as some kind of poly
logarithmic constant that i put here as
lambda times one over square root of t
where t is the number of times you're in
that state taking that action
and what i think is so beautiful about
all of these approaches
is a priori it's kind of unclear how to
do exploration in an mdp
like the dynamics are complicated
right
so you would think that you would need
to change or modify yeah
oh so this lambda is poly logarithmic
with respect to s a k
and a high probability factor
yeah and so what i think is super nice
about this style of approach is it turns
out that the most simplest thing you
could do just add on a standard
exploration term allows you to explore
and order enough in order to get a
regret guarantee
and so
just to be able to directly contrast the
estimates for the q function and the
true
from solving the value iteration again
unknown reward and
plug in an estimate
and add on some additional bonus term
here in order to incentivize exploration
and in order to relate this to the
discussion from yesterday
you can think of an mdp
when the horizon is equal to one as a
bandit
because you're just making one decision
that's it you don't care about the
future value
so this term is nothing it's zero
and so your estimate for the reward
is the empirical plus a bonus term
and so it turns out that you're able to
take this model based algorithm and if
you apply it to a bandit
it exactly reduces to the same ucb
algorithm that we saw yesterday
where our estimates for the mean reward
is the reward plus
this exploration term
and the arm that we play
is the one that maximizes this
yeah so just to clarify the though
the t here is the number of times i've
seen this eight action pair yeah
yeah
and
taking this style of approach and
relating it back to these three
invariances the algorithms need to do
we have the bottom one for free
because the policy we pick is playing
greedy with respect to the estimates
the top one
we added on a term that scales as one
over square root of t you can use
standard concentration inequalities to
say that's the deviation and so by
adding it on
you're able to show this
expression here
and
with a little bit of algebra you're also
able to show the second expression here
and so with this
you are able to get a regret guarantee
for this particular style of algorithm
that looks like this
um so the algorithm that i showed here
is presented in
this paper here and it's been modified
tweaked slightly and later works in
order to improve the right slightly to
get this but can talk about that after
um and so the regret guarantee for this
algorithm first it scales square root of
k
so we're sublinear with respect to the
number of episodes which is good we're
able to take it and obtain a sample
complexity guarantee
we're polynomial with respect to the
horizon
and square root with respect to the
number of states and actions
and in a min max setting people have
constructed min max lower bounds to show
that this has the optimal dependence on
the number of episodes it has to scale
in a worse case with respect to the
square root of k
but it is a model-based algorithm
and so its time and space complexity is
worse because you're estimating the
transition distribution which takes more
memory it takes more time in order to
execute
and this last dependence on h is still
kind of current research people have
worked on trying to shave factors on h
here but pay in terms of s and a and
other ways
and just to emphasize again this regret
guarantee is worst case
we saw in the bandit literature that we
were actually able to improve on square
root of t we were able to get
logarithmic in t
and just like the regret guarantee that
we saw before we got square root of k
and later i'll talk about
recent work um that has been able to get
this log k dependence instead
and again these regret guarantees
they're very much worst case they're not
capturing particular problem structure
that you see
and then also i wanted to briefly say
that we added these kind of arbitrary
exploration terms that look like lambda
over square root of t
people when they actually implement rl
algorithms in practice they do not do
that what they do is just called epsilon
exploration where with some probability
epsilon you sample an action randomly
um it just for the theoretical
guarantees you need to do the bonus
based exploration
is that because epsilon greedy is
actually more better and crowded yeah so
it's because it performs better in
practice and in order to
if you run experiments of these kind of
discrete tabular settings randomly
sample an mdp and compare epsilon greedy
versus the optimal choice of the bonus
term lambda to additionally tune that
constant lambda we see that epsilon
exploration most times also works better
yeah
okay
okay i'm trying to compare the
generative models because
yeah so even if you encoded the time
step and the state information the model
is still fundamentally different from a
generative model because given an
arbitrary state you need to
in this in order to obtain information
about it you need to design a policy or
use a policy that gets to that state
whereas in a generative model you just
say oh this is a state i care about
go to the simulator and sample a
transition part
okay
so
that was the model based approach and
next up is the model 3 approach
again the key difference is that instead
of estimating the rewards and
transitions we're estimating the q
function directly
we play greedy with respect to the
estimates and there's better time and
storage complexity because it's only hsa
instead of h s squared a
and for this streetcar did an amazing
job earlier presenting the q learning
algorithm
and so
the model free algorithm for the regret
minimization standpoint is q learning
with one modification
where
you add on this exploration term
okay
so instead of having this kind of d min
parameter that we saw before
in order to get the regret guarantees we
deal with that by adding on this
exploration here to our estimates of the
q function
where again
we're estimating this q function along a
sample path under the current policy
our estimates are updated in terms of a
linear combination of the old estimate
plus
the other form of the the
learning rate parameter times a one step
reward plus estimated value plus this
exploration term
what's interesting about this
is that the original paper showing the
regret guarantee for this model-free
algorithm has a particular choice of
learning rates that is required in order
to get the analysis to work
and so that learning rate that you need
to do depends on the horizon h
and it looks like h plus one over h plus
t
and
this is needed to some extent in order
to initially get
it still satisfies the normal like
learning rate optimization guarantees
where if you sum it over t it is
infinite and if you sum it squared it is
finite
so
we still satisfy the normal like robin's
monroe condition
but
this dependence on the horizon enforces
that the learning rate favors kind of
more later updates
and intuitively i like to think about it
as one issue of these model-free
algorithms is the way information is
propagated backwards across steps
in the model based algorithm you are
solving the full bellman equations and
so if you learn something new on the
last time step
that information will get propagated all
the way back to the first time step
whereas with these model free algorithms
it gets done a little bit slower because
you're only updating one
estimate of the q function on a sample
path
and so with this
we have a regret guarantee again
we have the same square root of s a k
term
which we wanted so we have
optimal dependence on k
but
if you remember from before the model
based algorithm had h to the three
halves and so this model free algorithm
has h to the five halves
there's been some work on
improving on the h to the five halves i
think they've gotten it down to h
squared which is still worse than h to
the three halves i think that's the best
result that we know so far though
and so
just like the presentations that we saw
before the regret analysis for this
particular algorithm has strong
relations to stochastic approximation
from robbins monroe and srikant's
presentation from earlier
again it has the optimal dependence on k
in this min max setting
better time and space complexity because
you're not estimating the transition
distribution and again this dependence
on h people have studied improving on
this factor and paying for it
differently in terms of the state action
space dependence
and i want to kind of wrap up this
discussion showing some kind of folklore
comparisons of people who are
implementing the difference of these
model-based and model-free algorithms in
practice
so i've shown two types of value-based
approaches so
the most obvious question is in practice
how can you compare the performance and
what is typically observed is that the
performance of model based algorithms is
better than model free
definitely true in the discrete setting
once you start adding function
approximation the answer is a little bit
more unclear
but
the same kind of fact is typically
observed that model based has better
performance
however the model based algorithms have
more compute
because you need to somehow estimate
this transition distribution which in a
parametric model is very complicated
plug that into these bellman equations
which for a random neural network model
of the transition distribution evaluate
expectations is now also hard to do so
definitely mark compute
and something that i think is
interesting is to try and understand a
trade-off between
min max regret and also the storage and
compute requirements
this is something that's been done in
bandits
where you say
if you have a bandit model you have k
arms but you can only maintain a finite
number of statistics that's smaller than
k
how does the regret change in terms of
the number of estimates you're allowed
to maintain
here our model based algorithm has more
data more compute we see it has better
regret and is that fundamentally because
it has more information
or potentially it's not
okay any questions about these model
based and model free algorithms
it sounds like this is just a high level
question uh it sounds like you estimated
the entire transition matrix like you
know
s s a squared by s a squared
or whatever it is yeah
sorry s a squared by s uh what if you
know that that matrix has some structure
is there work on this that either
reduces the complexity or there's better
guarantees yeah so there has been a lot
of follow-up work under different
assumptions or models that you make on
either the q function or the reward and
transitions and typically these
parametric representations that people
do are one of the two either assume
something parametric about the q
function or assume something parametric
about rewards and transitions
and so in a setting when the reward and
transitions are like
inner products in terms of a known
future representation there's also
regret guarantees that scale
square root of d square root of k where
d is the dimension of the future
representation
and so i guess that kind of brings us to
the next kind of discussion which is all
of the regret guarantees that i
presented our worst case
we saw regret guarantees that scale in
terms of square root of k not
logarithmic of k
and so
model-based and model-free algorithms
have been extended using
a similar style of analysis that's
presented in this paper here to get
logarithmic project guarantees for both
model-based and model-free settings with
slight modifications of the algorithms
that you saw before
there's also been work uh trying to
understand this kind of quote-unquote
variance dependence similar to the
variance dependence we saw in the bandit
setting from yesterday too
and also just like zee's question from
before there's a long list of
assumptions on the q function or the
rewards and the transitions being low
rank or linear or parametric under
different dimension models and come up
with regret guarantees
under the smorgasbord of dimensional
assumptions you can put on the
underlying model
and so all of this kind of discussion i
think really relates to what we have
done so far
which all of the discussion we've had
today has been
designing algorithms specifically for
this discrete setting with the exception
of srikant's presentation where we
optimize over these linear policies in
terms of a known representation
and so even if the problem that you're
actually applying it to is tabular like
let's say you want to code it up you
need to make an estimate of the q
function you go to numpy you tell it to
make the estimate and you turn into
something that looks like this where
suddenly you can even store an estimate
of the q function within your memory
and so
this i think
leads to what is most uh summarized as
the current research for reinforcement
learning is trying to design algorithms
that scale
and in order to do this i think that
there's two main assumptions that people
do
one is
apply function approximation to the
underlying
problem the second is additional
modeling assumptions on the underlying
problem and this is something that i've
also worked in and a lot of the people
in the roman and i think is something
that we should also be discussing this
semester as well on how different
modeling and function approximation
settings could be incorporated in
reinforcement learning
so with that i will stop here ask if we
have any questions
before wrapping up
optimal dependence on k do we have lower
bounds in this segment
[Music]
decide with a reference on it
so this paper here shows lower bounds
with respect to k
um
oh because of the okay i will tell you
afterwards
but there is a paper that shows
fundamental lower bounds with respect to
k
but fundamental lower bounds with
respect to these other parameters the s
and the a and the h dependence is still
ongoing people have been able to shape
factors like that shade h
no dependence on h but pay exponentially
in sma
and
people have done
achievability guarantees you can achieve
it but there hasn't been a mid max
setting um
for the rest of the parameters
wait those are the keto words
the k that k1 follows
um
you get each
square root of k from
all right i think we'll take the rest
offline uh so thanks everyone again for
coming to another great day of tutorials
we'll continue tomorrow uh meeting at
nine uh starting at 9 30
and we'll start with anupam's talks on
competitive analysis
i